anything else that you want to say is
there any
any uh grievances any axes you want to
grind
anybody here you want to seek revenge
upon everyone here is great uh you and i
have to talk later
i'm kidding i'm kidding kelly ripa's son
michael consuelos has
something to say about his mom's cheeky
instagram pic
i can't stand social media i really
can't it's such a minefield
on monday kelly posted this sexy
swimsuit selfie with her hubby mark
consuelos
checking out her backside with his mouth
wide open
in awe and on thursday their 24 year old
son
stopped by live with kelly and ryan and
called out his mom
how do you feel about the pictures of
mommy and daddy when she posts them
oh man um look it's
the one recently where it was the what
do you mean
you know you know what i mean yeah we
all know what he means
oh my gosh i don't even want to think
about it in our family everything is
left unsaid
and later after kelly got a little
embarrassed by ryan and michael
suggestively joking about quarantining
alone during the pandemic
he calls back to those sexy insta-posts
oh you have no room to make that face
after what you post on your instagram
michael
um michael i'm curious
and while michael made an appearance on
his mom's show he's
also appeared on his dad's cw series
riverdale
it's a normal thing people do this
michael plays a younger version of
mark's character
hiram i mean it's a it's a bucket list
for us as parents to have our
our son at least you know him play me a
younger version of
the character that i play i think it's
really great you know some of the crew
here
didn't know it was him and they're like
oh my god they really did well i said
it's like wow they did a great job he
looks just like him
not only does michael look just like his
famous dad he
sounds like him too everyone keeps
telling me that and i think
that the difference is that you know my
dad is my voice but with confidence
so you know when talking i'm like you
know i gotta sound like i know what i'm
doing
yep so mark and kelly's oldest son is
following in their showbiz footsteps
something that came as a surprise to the
daytime talk show host
you were so like anti-being on camera
there were years here where i couldn't
even mention your name
right what is it now that has changed
your mind
i've been so opposed to it for a long
time and i just like
why why why you know it's fun i enjoy it
um you were always acting as a kid
that's what i realized like you know
this isn't
directing in the writing a lot it's fun
but i think i was better suited for the
other stuff so
that's why i tried it and i ended up
really enjoying it
and kelly says she's seen a big change
in him since he started acting
and you know i have to thank you because
it was working on your show that
convinced me to become an actor
this isn't for me ever since you become
an actor i've watched you
like blossom as a personality he's just
like
confident i don't know i feel good i
think it's the suit you know it is i
remember
i will say this i remember starting out
as an actor and
being riddled with confidence and it's
something that you know really only 30
40 years in the business beats out of
you so
hold on to it now while you're here et
was with
michael and his dad on the set of
riverdale in 2018
and he opened up about how he landed the
role
michael i've got to say congratulations
your first ever acting gig
did you have to audition i did actually
a friend of mine had texted me a while
back
asking me if uh i was gonna make a cameo
or something because in season two
i made a cameo as a picture of my dad in
like in the wrestler episode yeah he was
he was he was me as a younger um
hire him in in the trophy case it's his
photo they called him and see it asked
my feet audition
my first ever audition mark what kind of
advice did you give nothing i told him
just to
memorize his lines he already had him
memorized and i know that your
daughter's a big riverdale fan
she loves it so are you getting cool
brother points right now
you know what uh she texted me
which never happens like hey good job
i'm like oh wow
i guess i'm cool i guess i'm cool now
you